an absurd ideological belief is actually
a form of tribal signaling it signifies
that one's ideology is more important to
them than reason itself than truth
sanity reason and to one's allies this
is an oath of unwavering loyalty to
one's enemies it is a threat display so
it's not always about what's true it's
often about how does this make me look
to my tribal compatriots and to my
enemies
tell me your background how did you come
to write long twitter threads that
hundreds of thousands of people see
so my original background is in tech
and i was working sort of on
uh search algorithms and things like
that and um
basically tasked with sort of ensuring
that people get directed to the right
information
but i sort of started losing interest in
that when i realized that the main
problems
with
the
internet were not actually caused by
algorithms
they're actually caused by people
because algorithms are basically
just a reflection of human behavior
so
once
that sort of epiphany came to me
i decided that it would actually be more
productive for me to actually understand
the core of the problems with the
internet and when i say the problems
with the internet i mean things like
misinformation and polarization and
things like that so
i decided to sort of move away from tech
and sort of explore human psychology a
little bit more um so i basically
started freelance writing and sort of um
you know understanding sort of trying to
understand um psychology and how that
sort of uh integrates with the sort of
digital age and how it's caused so many
problems and things like that um so yeah
i've been gradually trying to build up a
following on twitter
and uh
it's been working quite well so far and
then hopefully i've got some uh
enough people interested that i can
actually start to really um explore this
topic um
properly and as a full-time job it's my
hope i think so man the couple of tweet
threads that i've seen from you that i
got linked by some listeners are they're
monsters total my like 50 000 likes on a
couple of them and
40 tweet threads long so i got sent this
by one of the people that listens to the
show and i just fell in love with it so
i want to go through i'm going to harass
you today and ask for some insights into
some of the concepts that you came up
with and we'll see how many
we get through today so the first one
first tweet the law of very large
numbers given a wide enough data set any
pattern can be observed a million to one
odds happen eight times a day in new
york city population of eight million
the world hasn't become crazier we're
just seeing more of everything what's
that mean
so that's basically the story of twitter
they see that that sort of explains all
of twitter um
so
the whole thing about news is that news
is only news if it's surprising if it's
interesting
uh if it's not interesting it's not news
so people only share things that are
surprising and
and as a result of that
what happens is that if you've got a
theme a twitter feed and people are just
sharing things that they find unusual
it gives you a distorted perspective of
the world because
you're not seeing reality
you're seeing the exception to reality
you're seeing what's surprising you know
and the cumulative effect of this is
that it can really sort of send you
bonkers it can send you crazy
because you just get a completely um you
know distorted view of reality and
um you know
this this is something that occurs
regardless of what your beliefs are um
it really you know it's a universal
experience so if you're on the left
you're just going to constantly see
um things that would you know be sort of
surprising and sort of interesting and
outrageous to the left so
you'll see you know racism and you'll
see a lot of uh instances of corporate
greed um bigotry you know transphobia
all that kind of stuff so
that will lead you to believe that the
world is more bigoted and more greedy
and just more corrupt than it actually
is because you're just seeing these sort
of cherry-picked examples of the worst
of humanity and the same goes with if
you're on the right and you know or you
know you're anti-woke and whatever if
you're following um sort of you know
libs of tip tick tock great account
yeah yeah
it's a hilarious account and it's very
entertaining but if that's all you're
following if it's just those kinds of
anti-work accounts um then you're gonna
basically all you're gonna see is just
you know um hollywood celebrities acting
crazy and you're gonna see these
academics you know with this kind of
critical race theory craziness
and you're just gonna see that just over
and over again and it's going to
you know even if you're not conscious of
it it's going to basically
fool your brain into thinking that this
is the norm that you know this madness
this basically the extremism
is going to is the norm basically so
what that does is that it basically
creates this sense of threat
and it makes you feel that the basic the
whole world is hostile and this is what
drives people further to the extremes
because they think oh my god you know
there's basically a woke apocalypse or
oh my god you know racism is everywhere
so
this basically causes people to double
down on their beliefs and to say you
know oh my god you know we need to do
something about this and it basically
makes people militant have you ever read
10 reasons not to get famous by tim
ferriss
just an article online it's about half
an hour long
and [ __ ] man like it's so interesting
and in it one of the things that he
highlights is that most people are
shooting for fame they want to try and
get as big of an audience as possible
but what happens when you overshoot fame
and you get 150 million or a 300 million
person audience and i think he said
one percent around about one percent of
the population are psychopaths and he
was like okay
in a in an audience of 150 million
people
that's a lot of psychopaths so
his his point was that when you start to
spread the net wide enough the
exceptions start to be able to band
together to the point where you have so
many um
outliers
that they dominate your experience and i
guess this is kind of what you're seeing
you know for all that i find limbs of
tick tock kind of it it's funny and sort
of ridiculous it does irritate me in a
way because i know that it's a
misrepresentation of what most
well-meaning people on the left must
have and it irritates me because i think
like outraged at what these people are
actually saying so
yeah i am
it's a difficult one man and it's just
that limbic hijack race to the bottom of
the brain stem that you immediately
respond to
yeah absolutely and i mean um you know
further to what you were saying about
sort of you know the psychopath thing
you know it sort of increases the thing
the number of psychopaths well the
problem is is that there's something
called negativity bias i don't know if
i've included this in one of my mega
threads i don't think i have bonus round
yeah bonus round yeah um so negativity
bias is basically
the human tendency to um remember
and to sort of give more focus and
attention to
negative information rather than
positive information and so if you've
got an audience um like tim ferriss for
instance i think he's got 1.5 million
followers probably more than that um if
you've got a huge number of followers
um you know you can sort of read through
your your um notifications and you'll
see a lot of compliments after you tweet
something you know and you see oh you
know this is nice it's nice you know
this person loves what i'm writing
that's great and then suddenly you'll
get that one negative comment
and your mind will sort of focus on that
negative comment even if you've got like
you know 90 99
positive comments that one percent is
going to remain in your mind more than
the 99
of comment because you know that
negativity is something that you have to
react to and this goes back to our
evolutionary history you know it
obviously is more important for you to
be able to react to negative stimuli
than to positive stimuli because
negative stimuli constitute an
existential threat so you have to react
to them a lot more quickly and a lot
more harder than you would to a positive
stimulus and so as a result of that
people
even if there's only a small number of
psychopaths even if there's a small
number of rude people on twitter if
you've got a massive following and you
see that those small you know the small
um numbers those are gonna be inflated
and you're gonna get this kind of
distorted perspective and it's gonna
bring you down and it's going to make
you depressed and this is another
problem with with twitter is that
it kind of
it takes a lot more positivity
than negativity to affect you you know
and there's because of this disparity
you're always going to feel depressed if
you spend too long on twitter because
you're just going to remember the
negative things you're going to remember
the negative news stories rather than
the positive ones you're going to
remember the negative comments that you
get from people rather than the positive
ones and you know again the cumulative
effect of this is that it makes you feel
depressed and it just kind of brings you
down and it it just
it's not healthy for your brain because
your brain's not designed for this kind
of information you know
and so
it's basically um
it just brings down that's why probably
one reason why we have such a depression
epidemic you know an anxiety epidemic as
well is just because of this sort of
the importance of validation and how
that can be easily sort of um you know
just obliterated by just one negative
comment right next one the peter
principle people in a hierarchy such as
business or government will be promoted
until they suck at their jobs at which
point they will remain where they are as
a result the world is filled with people
who suck at their jobs
right yeah well this one was is kind of
more of a humorous one i mean i think
it's probably true in in in a lot of
instances it's not true in every
instance
because some people might choose to
remain where they are then they might
love that job and they might just want
to do it despite the fact that they
could do better jobs you know i know a
few people personally who have actually
declined promotions because they they
like where they are currently and they
want to do that work rather than a
managerial role or whatever but i think
it is true um as a general rule i think
um
you know it's just this kind of game
there's this whole hierarchical game
where
people are always trying to impress the
people above them and then you know
as long as they can do that they will be
promoted and they will you know sort of
rise in the in the hierarchy but
once they can't
the investment in that person is too um
big to let them go you can't just fire
them because you've trained them you've
built up a relationship with them so
it makes sense sort of um to just keep
them where they are you know to prevent
them from being able to do any more
damage by just containing what their
responsibilities are essentially you
know
you see this in um in sales
organizations right someone comes in
they're a good salesperson they become a
good
head salesperson or senior salesperson
and then eventually because humans in a
meritocracy within an organization they
naturally want to progress and be
promoted because they have this desire
for growth you end up eventually
losing a good sales person and gaining a
shitty manager because this person was
never built to be a manager they were a
mint salesperson
they don't want to be told that they
can't be promoted because they have this
natural desire for growth you can't not
promote them because then they're going
to leave and go somewhere else and be a
good salesperson until they maybe do get
to have a shitty manager job position
within that um but by promoting them you
lose the person that was good at sales
and you gain the person that can't
manage
yeah absolutely
i think there's this sort of faulty sort
of sense of success that people have
which is that if you're successful
at one thing you can be successful at
anything you know and um so somebody
who's been successful let's say um who's
basically done really well in
engineering or something um somebody
will think oh you know this guy because
he's so successful in engineering he
must make great manager and so they'll
promote them to a sort of managerial
role but the thing is is that that
person has spent their entire life
doing engineering and that's why they're
so good at engineering so to try to sort
of just you know assume that just
because they're successful as an
engineer they're going to make the great
manager i think this is a bit of a
you know sort of a fallacy that
is quite surprisingly common um
you know when i you know places that
i've worked i've found that sort of
people would just be promoted just
purely based on numbers just um you know
sort of their their statistics sort of
as it were rather than do they actually
have the skills to succeed in a very
sort of
uh very different environment that
they've been working on and um as a
result of that i think there are a lot
of people who just aren't really
qualified at what they do and you see it
all the time you just see incompetence
all the time you know and it's it's the
rule rather than the exception and it's
i think that yeah the peter principle
does have
a large part to play in that i don't
think it's the only factor but i think
it's um i do think it's it's certainly
one of the factors yeah next one uh the
golden hammer when someone usually an
intellectual who has gained a cultish
following for popularizing a concept
becomes so drunk with power he thinks he
can apply that concept to everything
every mention of this concept should be
accompanied by a picture of nasim talib
i think i was a bit mean spirited when i
wrote that
if i was to write that mega thread again
today i probably wouldn't go so hard on
tele um i was a little bit i was
thinking of telling when i wrote that
because um
i basically i've been following him on
twitter and i just noticed that pretty
much everything that came across him
every every sort of
uh idea that he was talking about he
would link it back to one of his ideas
which he had written back so it would
either be something about
anti-fragility or the lindy effect or
black swans you know and yeah these are
these are quite sort of fundamental
principles and they do have quite
far-reaching implications but it was
pretty obvious to me that what he was
doing
was he was essentially um selling his
book by just sort of
make making his ex his explanations as
wide as possible so you know he was
basically saying that you know if you
want to understand
a
read my book if you want to understand b
read my book if you want to understand c
read more he was basically linking
everything to his book and i think that
this is something that obviously it's
not just guilty of this he was just the
example that i thought of at the time um
it's anybody i've found it's actually
something that's quite common on twitter
when you see um somebody who's just
written a book and they've got a new
concept you know they will try to
explain everything in terms of that
concept and i think half of it is
because
they actually have spent so long on this
idea that it's kind of becoming an
obsession and
confirmation bias means that they're
going to just you know they're going to
see
any sort of uh any any sort of way that
they can make their explanation the
explanation they'll do that
that that's half of the explanation i
think the other half is that
um it's probably a conscious decision um
to just sell that book i think you know
i think another bit of it's the in-group
out group dynamic as well that by
highlighting this is the language of our
people if you understand what i'm
talking about you're one of the
initiates if you don't understand what
i'm talking about you're one of the
heretics
absolutely yeah this is uh something
known as shiblets and um
i think this is quite common on on
social media as well
people form um lingo they form these
concepts these words
which signal to others of the same tribe
that they are a member of the in group
and they're called shibboleths and um
they are actually a very very very sort
of central part of tribal life um to
have this kind of code
yeah you know everybody's got it you
know like people on the right for
instance use the word based a lot you
know and stuff you know and then you've
got people on the left who've got their
whole you know academic sort of stuff
about you know white fragility and all
that kind of stuff so everybody's got
their own sort of code sort of system
which they use to sort of reinforce
their in-group status and you know sort
of you know reinforce these
relationships they have with other tribe
members
um so yeah i think that that could be a
part of it as well yeah right
brandolini's law aka the [ __ ]
asymmetry principle it takes a lot more
energy to refute [ __ ] than to
produce it hence the world is full of
unrefuted [ __ ]
yeah
um
i think one of the reasons why
social media
is just so
full of [ __ ] um to put it
put it bluntly is because
it doesn't really take much time or
effort to post something that's wrong
and if you think about the kinds of
people
who don't think very much about what
they post
they're going to be able to post a much
faster rate than people who do think
about what they post
um so because of that rule
most of twitter mostly your twitter
timeline most of your facebook
um sort of you know timeline is going to
be
composed of people who haven't thought
through what they're actually saying
because obviously they can post a much
faster rate and at a much greater rate
than people who think very carefully
before they post
and as a result of that it creates the
impression that people are actually
stupider than they actually are like i'm
i'm not being funny but when i when i
first joined twitter in 2014
one of the first thoughts that i had was
my god there's a lot of stupid people on
this planet you know
that was actually one of my thoughts you
know i just couldn't believe it i'd
never been exposed to so much stupidity
when i just looked at twitter for the
first time and saw all of these idiotic
comments i just couldn't believe it and
and part of that was because i'd
actually be i'd fallen under the
illusion of brandolini's law um i had
basically been given this false
impression of people
by the
over-representation of people who don't
think before they post
there are a lot of very smart people out
there but they
they sort of um are very anxious and
they tend to really really think very
very hard before they post and as a
result that they don't post very often
and so you don't see their tweets very
often you see the stupid tweets a lot
more often than you see the the
the intelligent
tweets have you had a look at the
statistics around the percentage of
people who contribute the highest volume
of social media posts on twitter have
you seen this
it's like it's like the pareto principle
on steroids it's like
two percent of twitter users account for
90
of
the content that gets posted and um that
wouldn't surprise me
i can believe that i can believe that
very easily because i mean you know when
i when i first joined twitter i sort of
just followed anyone and everyone really
and um there was just so many of the
tweets were just like oh i just made a
bacon sandwich it tasted very good you
know it's lovely just stuff like that
you know and there's there are a small
number of people who post stuff like
that all the time and they just they're
responsible for just filling up twitter
with junk you know that's why you have
to be very um very discriminatory i
think on twitter you have to be very
careful about who you follow and i think
it's a good idea to block as well i used
to be against blocking because i thought
it was kind of like you know unfair on
people because you're kind of dismissing
them out of hand but i've come to the
conclusion that there's too many people
in this on earth for you to have any
time for nonsense
so
i would advise people to just block if
if somebody's posting stuff that's got
very low information density when i say
information density what i mean is um in
a single tweet how much information are
they actually giving you you know if
they're not giving you very much
information or if it's irrelevant nation
it's a good idea just to block them or
mute them um probably mute them if they
haven't been rude to you i usually block
people who are rude to me um but i mute
people quite often because i feel that
um you know it's
what they're doing is they're muscling
out other people on your timeline who
have more thoughtful thoughts
so
you know it's like it's it's very
important i think to do this because
it's the difference between twitter
being a hell site and twitter being like
a digital disneyland basically
it's that's the difference you know if
you're just very careful about how you
create your information
um follow the right accounts
block and mute a lot really liberally
then you'll find that brandolini's law
is not so influential on your life
anymore because people will be thinking
a lot more carefully before they post
and you know
that will sort of offset the sort of
effects of the law
the best thing i ever did was limit
myself to
99 people that i follow that's it yeah
it's the best thing that i ever did and
twitter is such a beautiful place for me
now i see articles i'm interested in i
very rarely see retweets of stupid stuff
and i've got in the back of my mind i've
got some sort of little
limbic clicker of how many strikes
someone's on and then if it if within
the space of a month someone annoys me
too many times it's like all right well
there we go there's a slot that's opened
up who i i don't know who i had to kick
off in order to start following you uh
but whoever it was unlucky right next
one uh
the tockville paradox
is about have i pronounced that right
yeah
tockville paradox as the living
standards in a society rise
the people's expectations of the society
rise with it the rise in expectations
eventually surpasses the rise in living
standards inevitably resulting in
disaffection and sometimes in populist
uprisings
yeah
so
this is a very important one i think
because this is a very powerful counter
argument
against um the people who see racism
everywhere who see you know
bigotry and all that kind of stuff
um you know there's this whole concept
of how on the left um
how sort of systemic racism has got
worse
and how you know um basically it's
almost
if you were to believe what was sort of
posted you know in the new york times
and stuff like that it would seem like
there's an epidemic of racism
and misogyny and transphobia and you
know all these other phobias and isms
um
but what's actually happened is that
our
conception of these things has actually
widened
so yeah that's another one concept creep
that was yeah yeah yeah the con links in
with with top build paradox quite well
quite easily
because they they're both sort of
referring to the same general principle
but in slightly ways so i'll probably
just do both of them together so
um so concept creep is basically when
your your definition of a certain
concept expands
when that thing becomes less common so
for instance misogyny is an interesting
one
so the original
um
sort of uh concept of misogyny was that
it was sort of like a violent hatred of
all women basically it was this belief
that women were um
inferior and that you know um or it was
something to do with sort of that they
they should give over their sexual
reproductive rights to men female racism
almost
yeah yeah kind of yeah it was bigotry
directed at females so that was the
original um sort of concept of misogyny
but
as the world became more enlightened and
um sort of you know women's rights were
put on parity with men's
and sort of there was more equality
that old sense of the term no longer had
much relevance in the west i mean it
still has a lot of relevance in the east
because there's still a lot of that kind
of misogyny in the east but in the west
there's not so much of it anymore
so
the the uh the oxford dictionary
actually changed the definition of
misogyny and it became um it went from
sort of hatred of women to it could be
dislike of individual women or it could
be dislike of particular groups of women
it didn't have to be like you know just
a sort of a blinding hatred of all women
and gradually
that that word has been sort of
appropriate now it's been um sort of
re-imagined again by by the left by the
modern feminist movement
um to now it can also basically mean um
it could be hatred of a particular woman
you know you see this a lot you see this
very often um you know somebody i mean
hillary clinton weaponized this new
definition of misogyny very very
cleverly
um
in the sort of election when she was
criticized you know by people she would
assume she would basically say that it
was because she was a woman she was she
was seeking to be the first female
president and they didn't want the first
female president because they were
misogynists
and this kind of thing so it was it was
politicized and it was basically
because of that
um how this links in with the top real
paradox is that
when you expand the definition of a term
that thing becomes more common again so
if misogyny in the traditional sense is
decreasing and then you increase
the scope of the word misogyny suddenly
the instances of misogyny are going to
increase again so it's going to seem
like misogyny is getting worse
when in fact it's not actually getting
worse the the definition of it is
expanding
and this applies not just to misogyny or
to words like races i mean racism is
another one you know
racism originally was
uh discriminating against people on the
basis of the color of their skin or
hating people because of the colored
skin now there's all these different
types of racism now we've got systemic
racism institutional all that kind of
stuff um you know they've expanded the
definition of racism to include things
like microaggressions and all this other
stuff you know so the
the the numbers of absolute instances of
racism have actually decreased but
because racism now means so much more
than it used to
you can easily find more examples of
racism now than you would have in the
past just because of and you know this
also links in with the law of very large
numbers you know
if you've got a wide enough data set you
can find any number of instances of
racism can cherry pick them and make it
look like it's worse
so
this is a paradox because
as
the
world gets better
because of the change in these ideas
it can make it look like the world is
actually getting worse
and a lot of people do believe the world
is getting worse and this is not just
something that's confined to the left um
you know you've got the
neo-reactionaries who are convinced that
the world is is heading to hell and they
believe that the world is actually going
to just fall apart
um you know so this is quite a common
belief this kind of apocalyptic uh sort
of belief system is is something that's
very common and i think it is largely a
result of the topical paradox because
the definitions of problems are
widening
poverty is another one in absolute terms
poverty has been dwindling it's been
being reduced i mean
a person living today the poorest person
in the west today is better off than
most nobles who are living you know in
the in the sort of medieval times
because they've got access to iphones
even if they're poor you know pretty
much everybody's got a phone or a laptop
and got access to the internet so in
absolute terms people are richer
than they were
in those days you know people have
access to much a wider range of foods
now than they used to have
um
so in absolute terms we've got much much
better but
there's this thing called relative
poverty which is how the un
um will measure that's how it measures
poverty it doesn't measure it in
absolute terms it measures it in
relative terms
so relative terms is basically um how
much poorer is the poorest person
compared to the richest person
you know so yes in if you measure things
like that if you measure poverty via
relative poverty
then that's wealth inequality i'm not
sure i'm not convinced that poverty fits
that definition but that's concept creep
again right
yeah absolutely exactly so that's
essentially what what this sort of
relative poverty is
relative poverty is wealth inequality
um it's basically the gap between the
richest and poorest
and it's not absolute poverty because
there used to be absolute property which
was you know if you're below a certain
income per year
regardless of how rich the richest
person is then you are in absolute
poverty but now it's done by different
um sort of criteria because
we because the world has just got so
much better that you can't really
measure things in absolute property
anymore so now we're thinking more about
wealth inequality and so the top rule
paradox basically to sum it all up
it makes the world look like it's
getting worse when fact is actually
getting better
and that's a big cause of problems
it's an interesting one to think about
that when
rightly as society develops kind of
steel man the side of the tock williams
um
why you would say that that would be a
good idea is we now have more access to
technology we have more wealth we have
more ability to actually deploy things
to improve well-being and happiness and
fulfillment and flourishing and blah
blah blah
therefore the
level of dexterity and resolution with
which we should be looking for problems
has to become increasingly fine as well
it's no point saying oh well we've got
rid of dysentery and
[ __ ] managed to get the mr the
measles mumps and rubella vaccine
therefore we fixed all the problems no
no there are more problems to continue
going but you're right that it's not
it's not necessarily about this linear
progression it's about the way that the
rules of the game continue to be played
that redefine it it's it's impossible to
compare progress of today with problems
of yesterday when the rule set that was
used yesterday and today are now
different
yeah absolutely i completely agree i
think um yeah absolutely you know i i
believe that wealth inequality is is
generally a bad thing and i do want to
see the people who are you know lifted
up absolutely
and i don't think that we should be um
content with where we are i think we
should always be looking to improve
the situation for people no matter how
well we have improved it in the past
but what the top build paradox
the true sort of um problem with topical
paradox
is not um that it stops us um trying to
make the world a better place the
problem is that it creates this sense of
pessimism
which can manifest in dangerous
ideologies um so you know you can have
this sort of left leftist sort of view
of
for instance you know the black lives
matter riots um last year they caused a
lot of damage um and you know i can
understand why people are angry i mean
you know george floyd should not be
killed the way he shouldn't be killed at
all but it was particularly egregious
the way he died
and um
you know so i can understand what that
made people angry but if people had
actually looked at the facts they would
see that the violence
against by the cops against
members of the black community has
actually decreased massively and corman
hughes is a great writer he
on race and stuff he wrote this thing
called the racism treadmill which is
that no matter how well
race relations uh become there will
always be people who will say that it's
not enough and that there needs to be
more needs to be done
and that it's space
it's not like that they're saying that
um
basically that they just need to improve
because that would be fine of course
race relations need to improve what
they're saying is that race relations
haven't moved at all basically they will
always say that race relations are still
as bad as they were in the 1950s
or 1900s when it's self evidently not
true you know
i mean there's been huge huge civil
rights um movements which have you know
given black people the rights to vote
the
the rights to go to school um with white
people you know and all these things
have happened sort of in the past
hundred years and so it's self
evidently false and yet these people
still believe that race relations either
haven't moved at all
since those times or that they've
actually got worse
and um this is you know it's just
it it's it is largely due to the
top-level paradox people just
can't see that these um they can't see
the sort of
the advances because they're sort of
they've been formed by language and
they've been fought by ideas and they've
been fooled by sort of
a lot of um ideologuing by the sort of
new york times and
you know these kinds of
publications which are always pushing
this sort of narrative that
um the world is getting more racist
the racism treadmill i like
i haven't spent much time watching
coleman hughes's stuff i've got john
mcwherter on in a couple of weeks and
he's he's got a new book called woke
racism which i haven't read yet but
he'll be interesting to speak to right
next one this is one of my favorites
because i adore the blog post that this
came from the toxoplasma of rage the
ideas that spread most and not those
everyone agrees with but those that
divide people most because people see
them as causes to attack or defend in
order to signal their commitment to a
tribe and this is scott alexander from
what used to be slate scar slate star
codex and he's now astral codex 10.
yep absolutely yeah yeah he's a great
writer um
so yeah this is a a very important one
also um
because you know there's this sort of
naive view that some people have which
is that people just want to know what's
true
and you know if you just only give
people the truth then everybody will be
enlightened and
you know the world will be
sort of rosy and everything will be
happily ever after kind of thing but
that's not how the human brain works the
human brain is not actually that
interested in true
um
what the human brain i mean the human
brain is interested in in creating an
uh a sort of image of reality that is
in line with evolution basically and
part of that evolution because most of
our lives if you look at human humans
have been around for about 200 000 years
and for approximately 180 000 of those
200 000 years so approximately 90
of human evolution has been spent in
hunter-gatherer lifestyles in tribal
societies
and as a result of that
we have tribal mentalities so we tend to
play status games within tribes and we
tend to have these kind of
internaciene um struggles and um
we also sort of
are very hostile to people who are not
of our tribe
and um
when it comes to information we often
try to use that information in ways that
will benefit our tribe or which will
benefit our status within that tribe
and so
this is one of the core things behind
sort of epistemology you know if you've
got a set of information and you give
that information to people they're not
going to process it as in is this true
or is this false they're going to
process it largely as
does this hurt or does it help my tribe
and this really explains a lot of the
sort of polarization that we're seeing
um
on the internet and
social media specifically um because
essentially what the culture war is the
culture war is
um a sort of a relic it's a vestige of
our tribal struggles
we have essentially sort of
re-primitivized technology
um to sort of
you know because we've basically we've
reverted back to this kind of caveman
sort of tribal ideology um because
of the way that um
twitter is sort of and facebook and
stuff are basically sort of arranged you
know so we form these communities online
which are essentially
tribes
and
we do not look at things as true or
false we look at them as how is this
going to benefit my tribe how is it not
going to benefit my tribe and
from that from that simple fact
you have polarization you have
misinformation you have all the big
problems that we are facing today as a
result of this one thing you know people
will tend to share information and i've
seen this happen so often that it's just
it doesn't even register anymore
where people will know something is not
completely accurate but they'll post it
anyway because it either demeans the the
enemy tribe or it makes their own tribe
look good and i mean there's plenty of
words for it there's one thing called
nut picking
nut picking is when you take the most
extreme
um sort of examples of the opposing
tribe
and then you use that to demonize the
entire enemy tribe so if you if you're
on the
on the left and you see a
and you want to sort of demonize the
right what you would do is you would go
to someone like stefan molyneux or
um you know like a richard spencer sort
of character someone who's unpopular
with most people someone who's very very
far away um and so you know then then
they would say oh look this person is
this person's a racist and and he's a
member of this tribe so they're all
racists you know and likewise if you're
on the right liberal tick tock
yeah yeah exactly yeah you'll get the
most woke person that you can find you
know somebody who basically thinks that
math is racist or something like that
and then you'll say oh look at this
person you know they're so woke this
this is what they won't believe they
believe that math is racist
and so you know it's these the people
who post these things they know that
they're just they know what they're
doing they know that this is not a
representative example you know it's
just they're taking an extreme and
they're using that to sort of demonize
the entire tribe and straw manning is is
basically the same sort of concept you
know where you you get you take what
somebody said and then you just
interpret in the worst possible way and
you people often do this
dishonestly they don't do it um sort of
unwittingly a lot of people do this
dishonestly so
you know
somebody says um you know
if they have concerns about immigration
for instance you know then you say oh so
what you're saying is that you hate all
immigrants you know you so you're a
racist you don't like brown people
basically so they'll take the worst
interpretation of what somebody has said
and then they'll basically you know
they'll use that to demonize a tribe so
this is this basically sums up pretty
much 99 of the culture war basically
there's an article by eric taurenberg
that i read a couple of weeks ago and he
talks about status games and some of the
idea pathogens that we're sort of seeing
at the moment
and one of the things that he
highlighted was that
some of the crazy ideas that people
share from their own tribe the ones that
they know to be false
they're almost commitment devices so
they're seen as commitment devices by
their own side look we all kind of know
that this thing's a bit mental
but you need to posit your position
alongside us as a show of faith and if
you don't it's a canary in the coal mine
that you might not be someone that is
aligned with our interests and that's
really really [ __ ] interesting that
this is some sort of like hazing
initiation
type
fealty
ceremony to check whether or not
everyone's on side
an absurd ideological belief
is actually
a form of tribal signaling
um
it signifies that one's ideology is more
important to them than reason itself
than truth sanity reason
and to one's allies this is an oath of
sort of unwavering loyalty uh to one's
enemies it is a threat display basically
so
it's it's not always about what's true
you know it's it's often about
how does this make me look to my tribal
um sort of compatriots and to my enemies
you know and i think a lot of that is
actually
it really does explain a lot of the
cultural um people are not saying what
they think is true they're thinking
they're saying what is going to sort of
favor them to their tribe they're saying
what they think is effective
yeah yeah all right next one uh
bulvarism
instead of assessing what a debate
opponent has said on its own merits we
assume they're wrong and then try to
retroactively justify our assumption
usually by appealing to the person's
character or motives explains 99 of
twitter debates
yeah and this also links in with what we
were just talking about i mean
you know people are not configured for
true and they're configured for these
tribal games and um
so often if you're if you're debating
somebody who's of a different tribe it
makes sense to just assume they're wrong
um rather than have to actually do the
hard work of actually you know analyzing
are they really you know telling the
truth it's just much easier and much
better just to assume that they're wrong
and then to work your way backward
through that and i mean i think
everybody's guilty of this i'm guilty of
it myself you know sometimes
if i'm arguing with somebody that i just
know that i'm going to disagree with i
will just i won't really pay too much
attention to what they're saying i'll
just look at the keywords that they're
using and then just be like oh okay why
make a value judgment from there tell
you what's the perfect example of this
that you see from the right as soon as
someone criticizes them they'll go onto
their profile and if they've got their
pronouns in their bio they'll just reply
with pronouns in bio case closed you're
like well yeah that is precisely
dealing with the the person not the
uh the argument
yeah and i think a lot of it
has to do with the format
of twitter as well i think um
you can't really have a decent debate on
twitter it's just not possible i've made
this comparison where i've said that
trying to have a debate on twitter is
like trying to have a sword flight in a
phone booth
um it's just not possible because you
don't have the space
yeah it's unwieldy you don't have the
space to really um to explore ideas and
so
people will tend to just take shortcuts
because they don't want to argue i mean
it's a laborious thing to actually get
into a twitter argument with somebody i
don't i don't do it
because it's just a waste of time most
of the time because you're not going to
change their beliefs they're not going
to probably change yours and it's just
going to result in insults and then just
eat rather than light
and you know what's the point in it when
you could be spending that time doing
something more productive one of my
favorite twitter followers adam tweeted
this earlier on twitter is too short for
specifics generalizations have to
suffice
midwits can't abide generalizations
they'll point out every exception and
demand you tweet a full thread then they
refuse to read the threads don't tweet
for midwit they are not your audience
yeah yeah it's true i mean
i i have to deal with this all the time
um every time i tweet
i have to sort of make a compromise
between accuracy and pithiness
um and the thing is is that i like
concision i like to just i like to say
witty one-liners right on twitter
but the thing is that if you say what do
you want liners you have to omit a lot
of context
and the context the lack of context is
where the people are going to be coming
up in your mentions and they're gonna be
accusing you of you know lacking context
you know the best the best reply to one
of those pithy little statements is well
like not everyone and you're like well
yeah obviously not everyone i wasn't
trying to be ex like exhaustive with
this
little aphorism that i've come up with
that rhymes so i think it's cute like
just
leave me allow it
yeah exactly yeah yeah i mean that's
what i mean twitter is really just um
is for very very brief general maxims
about the world it's it's not really for
anything
aphorism circle jerk isn't it all right
next next one this is one of my
favorites i really want to hear your
thoughts on this good hearts law
when a measure becomes a goal it ceases
to become a measure for example british
colonists tried to control snakes in
india they measured progress by the
number of snakes that were killed
offering money for snake corpses people
responded by breeding snakes and killing
them
yeah
yeah this is a very interesting one um
so when you have a system and then you
try to
um so optimize that system by reference
to a single metric
what normally happens
is that that metric will be gamed
er
history has shown that human beings will
always gain a system if they can do so
it's it's sort of like part of the human
makeup to try to do that we always try
to find loopholes we always try to you
know try to get sort of underneath
the sort of the fence and try and get to
the other side we try to we try to
always find our way around things and um
basically this is why
it's it's a bad idea to try to
um use metrics for anything because they
will always be games you can always you
can always find a way to manipulate
metric um with anything you know like
for instance i mean this
again this goes back to what we were
talking about with poverty and relative
poverty if you measure things in terms
of poverty and absolute poverty people
will change the sort of definition of it
or they will
um they will manipulate it in such a way
as to um
make it look like something it's not um
so
for instance if you are measuring
absolute poverty
and you are measuring it via salary or
by a yearly income which is how it was
measured
what people will do is they'll misreport
their their salaries um
because they want their area to be they
want themselves to seem like they're in
greater poverty than they actually are
in order to get more um help and from
people this is this is a bit of a vague
example
an example that i really love using is
um email capture so let's say that
you're a content creator that wants to
start building up your email list and
your goal the outcome that you're
looking for is emails how many emails
can i capture so what you say is this
ebook contains
a world winning lottery combination
formula that will guarantee to make you
one million pounds blah blah blah and
you post it everywhere and you get tons
and tons of emails but when people open
the pdf it's just blank there's nothing
in it it's like okay so you've gained
the outcome the outcome was get emails
but really
what was the distillation of the outcome
the outcome was get access to people who
genuinely want to hear what i have to
say in a good faith way that makes them
continue to want to hear what i have to
say
so by optimizing for that particular
outcome you've actually missed off the
thing that you were there to get
yeah absolutely and i mean it works in
so many different ways i mean again you
see this on twitter um
you know if you try to measure a
person's uh
credibility via the number of followers
that they've got for instance you know
um what happens kanye west has crushed
it yeah exactly
yeah yeah people game the system i mean
um what will happen is that people will
use underhand tactics to get followers
so what you actually get is you get the
most untrustworthy people having the
most followers so it's actually it's an
inversion of the original sort of
concept you know
um this happens i mean with everything
you know it's
it's basically the sort of this it's the
rule rather than the exception people
will always try to gain a system and and
laws are created in such a way as to try
to minimize this you know that's why you
have all these extra sort of additions
added to laws whenever whenever a
loophole is found um a new sort of law
will be uh sort of created to basically
close that loophole and this is a
constant game between
people trying to create the rules for a
system and people trying to gain the
system that is the essence of sort of
civilized society
the messiah effect most people don't
believe in ideals but people but in
people who believe in ideals most people
don't believe in ideals but in people
who believe in ideals hence why
successful religions tend to have human
prophets or messiahs and why when a
demagogue changes his beliefs the
beliefs of his followers often change
accordingly
yeah so this one i wasn't really sure
about including this one because this is
completely my own invention
that's what basically sort of um
separates this one from the others but
because i included one of my own from
the first thread i thought okay i'll
include one of my own in into this
thread it's still a nascent one which is
why the messiah the messiah effect is
not a great name
i just sort of spoke spirit of the no
moment name but um
it's something that i do feel is
generally true
i don't think it's true in every
instance again but it's it's something
that i feel is a general truth and this
is from my observations of people and i
think um
generally if you look at
people
um when they
during election time what they would
normally do is that they will normally
express
um sort of their sentiments towards a
certain person a certain politician
rather than towards an ideology um if
you ask people you know for instance if
you look at donald trump for instance if
you ask a trump supporter
what they like about trump's policies
most of them wouldn't really be able to
give you a very good sort of overview of
his policies
they would generally just say that i
like him him because i think he tells it
like it is you know he doesn't care
about what the establishment thinks um
he just you know he just basically does
what he wants to do he's independent and
all this kind of stuff so they would
generally fire off the qualities of the
person by the policies that he espouses
and i think that one of the reasons for
this is that
um policies are quite hard to understand
and they take a lot of uh sort of time
to really get to grips with you have in
order to understand trump's policies you
need to understand how economics works
you need to understand how the political
system works you need to understand how
um business and corporations and things
like work so there's a lot of um there's
a lot of things you have to understand
in order just to understand trump's
policies whereas if you
look at trump himself he's quite easy to
read you just all you've got to do is
just watch him on tv and you can see
aspects of his personality very very
quickly you don't need to have any other
knowledge so this is so it's a shortcut
basically it's a shortcut you we trust
people rather than ideas
and um it makes it makes it much easier
on our brain because then we can just we
can just delegate all the
responsibilities to that person rather
than have to think for ourselves it's
like they're a distillation of what they
represent
yeah absolutely yeah yeah we tend to
think of human beings in terms of
archetypes i think and
when we see somebody we think of what
they represent um as a symbol we see
people as symbols in a sense you know
and but a lot of people you know trump
symbolized um sort of this kind of
anti-establishment um sort of
independence basically he was
essentially like a wrecking ball that is
gonna sort of you know just tear apart
the
sort of polite society sort of you know
that govern
before him and then obviously to people
who like who don't like trump um he's
just this you know crude
sort of buffoon who is just an idiot
basically he doesn't really know
anything and he's a pathological liar
and that was basically that was for them
that was sufficient for him do you know
why another reason i think this might be
the case and perhaps it's a weakness or
a vulnerability of the 21st century i
don't know many people that genuinely
love a thing
i know people that love people but i
don't know many people that are actually
really passionate so if you ask someone
dude what do you really what do you
really care about what are you really
passionate about what do you love in
life
and
their family wouldn't they correct yeah
they don't tend to say a thing so when
you see someone
who is
outright caring this is from eliader
yukowski actually he highlighted that
most people take the piss out of the
rationalist movement not because they're
taking the piss out of the rationalist
movement but because not many people
love anything as much as rationalists
love the rationalist movement he says
it's just an uh an outlier effect to see
people that care a lot
about a thing and when you finally do i
think the presumption from
midways is
they know something
no one would be this brought in to any
idea
if there wasn't tons and tons and tons
of virtue behind it because i'm not i
think i'm smart and i'm not bought into
anything as much as this guy so i'm a
i'm gonna put my colors onto this
person's flagpole i'm gonna hold on to
those take uh coattails
because that's the person that's gonna
carry us forward
yeah absolutely yeah we generally do
have more of an affinity to people than
to ideas or things um
and i think
i think part of it is also the same
reason why we like watching uh hollywood
actors you know play parts and stuff
it's that we we get the archetypes from
these people
um you know we basically we see the way
that a certain person behaves and if we
like the way that it behaves we try to
emulate them we see them as a model for
our own behavior
and through that you know we sort of um
it's like a way that we kind of try to
improve ourselves by emulating other
people and if we see somebody that we
like think okay i'll be more like this
person
you know you can't really emulate an
idea you can't emulate a thing but you
can emulate a person
and because we are sort of mimetic
human beings you know we
learn by copying others
um it it's only natural that we're going
to sort of
migrate and sort of you know navigate
towards um people rather towards ideas
reactance theory when someone is
restricted from expressing a point of
view or pressured to adopt a different
point of view they usually react by
believing their original point of view
even more and then you did an article
about why
the cure the best cure for fake news is
more fake news as well which is related
to this i think yeah reactants theory is
one of the key arguments in my view
against
censorship
because what history has shown and by
history i mean just the past couple of
years um what stash what that has shown
is that
if you try to stop people from believing
something they're going to dig their
heels in harder because
dostoevsky actually made this point you
know a long long ago where he basically
said that um
what people want is not truth
what people want is they want to
exercise their free will they want to
they want to basically exercise their
free will and if that means going
against reason
they will choose freedom over reason
so
and he said this in a book called notes
it notes in the notes from the
underground
um it's a pretty good book
and basically
this is the idea behind reactants theory
which is that
if you tell people they can't do
something
they're going to feel like
they're under threat
they're going to feel that their freedom
is being
sort of reined in and they want to
exercise that freedom uh in order to
sort of feel
that they're not in order to sort of
assuage this feeling of claustrophobia
and the way that they do that is by
believing what they're believing even
harder and reacting even more
against you know what what is trying to
sort of stifle them um it's almost like
if you look at the sort of the story of
the garden of eden
when um you know god tells adam and eve
that they can't eat from the apple and
that makes them even more curious about
the apple and they're like okay he told
us not to eat the apple why why didn't
you do it now i really want to eat the
apple you know so they they become even
more sort of adamant to eat the apples
so this is a very sort of fundamental
idea and it's one that um
you see all the time you know if you
if you look at the way that censorship
works now i mean
most of the censorship um that occurs is
usually targeting um you know people who
are pushing what are regarded as
conspiracy theories things like q and on
um
the anti-vaxx anti-vaxxers and those
kinds of people and um
what these people will generally do when
they when they see their their posts
being deleted from twitter um is they're
not going to say oh okay right they
deleted it so that means it's wrong so
i'm not going to believe that anymore
they're going to they're going to do the
exact opposite they're going to say okay
these guys don't want truth to come out
so they're they're basically they're
censoring us because they are afraid of
what we have to say so that means that
we're right you know that's basically
that validates what we're trying to say
because if what we were saying wasn't uh
dangerous if it wasn't true they
wouldn't bother um you know they would
just point out why we were wrong they
wouldn't bother trying to censor uh you
know us so
basically it's counterproductive and you
see it with um what happened with parley
you know parley the social media
i think it's pronounced parlor
yeah it's spelt parlor but i think it's
pronounced parley at least that's what
yeah
um
yeah i mean i only knew this uh and i
only found this out yesterday in fact
it's called [ __ ] nothing now because
god knows where it is
well well it's back online it's actually
back online again now yeah it's on a
different server but what happened so
i'll just
sort of
quickly briefly um sort of uh delineate
what happened so
um after the the january 6 capital riot
uh there was a lot of pressure put on
the tech giants by um
by the biden and administration
uh to essentially um
you know uh
reign in these kinds of q and on
conspiracy theories and um
basically what uh amazon did is amazon
figured that one of the
uh
one of the websites using its platform
it's um its web server
this social media site called parlay
was basically a key to
organizing the riots so they essentially
deleted the website from their platform
and their their in their view this was a
good thing because this would ensure
that people wouldn't be able to
coordinate any further um sort of riots
but it actually had no effect because
everybody just went to alternate um
platforms platforms such as gab
and they basically just
did what they were doing before but now
they were extra angry because now they
they thought this is actually a
confirmation of everything that we have
been saying that they have actually you
know they've tried to silence us they've
tried to silence us on mass and so this
is clear that there's some kind of
conspiracy and this is the thing with
conspiracy theories is that
if you try
to conspire against the conspiracy
theory it becomes more evidence
conspiracy you know
and that's what essentially is is
happening with these kind of with
censorship
it appears to this to the conspiracy
theorists that censorship is a
conspiracy
that it's part of the conspiracy
in that sense conspiracy theories are
anti-fragile you cannot um you cannot um
defeat a conspiracy theory by conspiracy
because that just becomes part of the
conspiracy of that they believe in so
you know it sounds a bit sort of obvious
but this is something that a lot of
people who work for these um
uh these you know these sort of
fact-checking organizations and these
silicon valley uh sort of sensors a lot
of these people don't really realize
this and this is actually
one of the problems one of the problems
that i see with this
partially or a counterpoint to it
is that taking out individual
uh speakers that hold keystone positions
can be effective so i know that alex
jones has a particularly large audience
but his audience isn't going to grow
like the only way the infowars.com now
increases in size is by word of mouth he
can't advertise he's not got access on
social media you know donald trump now
when you see him on the internet you're
like oh look it's donald trump as
opposed to oh look it's donald trump
like it's it's a surprise rather than
something that's obvious and the example
that i use for this is milo yiannopoulos
like milo got totally unpersoned from
the internet and where the [ __ ] has he
got now he may be an easy example
because
he's just gone mental um
but
in some situations it might work
yeah i think with milo it was a very
peculiar case because he didn't just get
cancelled by the establishment he
actually got cancelled by his own peers
he got cancelled by the right yeah
because obviously you know he he did the
unthinkable you know he
basically tried to create an excuse for
pedophilia and um
so obviously i don't think anybody could
recover from that um no matter how far
to the right you are no matter how
pro-free speech you are you know you're
not gonna richard spence is not coming
to save you there no
exactly exactly so um i think that was a
slightly different but i understand what
you're saying i do think that it can
work sometimes and i do i think your
example of alex jones is a particularly
important one because i mean i got a lot
of criticism for writing a quiller
article in which although i
you know i reiterated that i'm i'm
basically pro free speech
i said that um it was actually
that alex jones was a threat to free
speech
um because and the reason for that
is because what he was doing is he was
essentially
um he was accusing
people of being child molesters with no
evidence and this guy has got millions
of followers and a lot of those
followers have got guns and they don't
take kindly to hearing about pedophiles
in their vicinity
and this obviously manifested with um
planet ping pong being shot up you know
luckily nobody was killed but
you know when you've got a guy who's cr
just basically creating these sort of
conspiracy theories and accusing random
innocent people of being pedophiled
that's actually pretty bad because that
creates um
violence in the real world and that's
not good because that intimidates people
it prevents people from wanting to speak
out against alex jones because if they
don't if they if they say something
against alex jones they might be sort of
you know assumed to be pedophiles too
and then people come after them so
i felt that alex jones was actually
creating it although he always talks
about freedom of speech and all this
stuff i felt that his actions in that
respect were actually um detrimental to
freedom of speech
but now the thing is yes alex jones was
he was taken off twitter and it had a
small effect he had a very small effect
not a huge one um because
you know he's still going viral he went
viral very recently on youtube despite
being banned from youtube he went viral
on twitter despite being banned from
twitter you know so it doesn't it
doesn't actually have a massive effect
does have a small effect
but the thing is is that this is all
going to come to an end very soon um
it's no longer going to be possible
people to be cancelled um by the
establishment within the next couple of
years
web 3.0 decentralization
bingo yeah you've got it yeah that's
exactly what's happening um so we've got
web 3 coming along and um
because that works on the blockchain um
primarily on on ethereum
it's it's
there's no um there's no regulatory body
there's no sort of centralized node in
that network so so nothing has to
there's no middleman basically nobody
has to
get their information going through a
router in order to get it to somebody
else it just it goes directly from one
pier to another
and because of that
um the old systems are not going to work
um very well as sort of regulating
people what people can and can't say um
you know you've got
for instance you know in the web 2
system you've got things like patreon
patreon can take your livelihood away
from you um if it thinks that you've
said something that it doesn't like
because in order to get payments you
have to go through patreon you can't
just get payments directly from your
from your users at least you couldn't um
until web3
so um you know that was one way that
they would leverage and their their
power against people in order to stifle
speech another one
yeah yeah and another way was like
facebook would be you know they could
they could just completely delete your
account
because your your entire um sort of
online personality is dependent on
facebook's platform so you can't really
um you know if you if you want to
uh continue to have business ties if you
want to continue to
you know have relationships online you
have to do what facebook tells you to
but this is all going to come to an end
i mean for most people not for everybody
but it's going to come to an end for a
large proportion of people um
with web3 because with web3
you're going to have
um all of this payments processing all
this kind of stuff it's all going to be
done on the blockchain and so
um because it's trustless because it's
permissionless
um
it's it's there's no no single person or
no single entity or no single
organization can um have
has the leverage to stop you from saying
what you want and that's a great thing
but the thing is it's not everybody is
going to be able to use web3 because
it's going to require
i think at least for the foreseeable
future it's going to it's going to
require a little bit of knowledge of
blockchains and things like so
um
i'm a bit worried actually um with the
way that things are currently going with
misinformation and censorship because
um there's actually there's going to be
the older generations like the boomers
and stuff who are going to continue to
use web 2 and then there's going to be
the younger more tech savvy people who
are going to use web 3.
and um
so
the people who are using web 2 they're
going to still be restrained by these
systems and as a result of that there's
going to be a kind of disparity between
these two classes i mean
one of the reasons you know there are
plenty of ethical arguments against
censorship and i'm sure your your
viewers have probably heard them all
already so i won't go into them but
there are also functional arguments
against censorship
and um there are three there are in fact
three three functional arguments against
censorship
um the first one is that censorship
doesn't really work because fact
checkers
are
not very good at their jobs um pretty
much all the fact checkers that work in
silicon valley
they have to do something they have to
basically um they have to be accredited
by something called the international
fact-checking network which runs out the
pointers institute in florida and this
is a very liberal organization like most
of its kind you know most organizations
it's kind it's quite uh it's very
heavily deliberate in fact it works very
closely with the southern poverty law
center which you might know um
has a tendency to just call everybody
far right i mean it was sued by majin
nawaz
for calling him far right and it was
forced to pay him
3.5 million dollars
and apologize publicly for for that you
know so i mean these guys these guys
don't just have a tendency to just
dismiss anything that doesn't agree with
them as far right
and these are the people who compiled a
database for the international
fact-checking network of fake news
websites for the fact checkers to use
this database had to be taken down after
it was revealed that it consisted pretty
much exclusively of conservative news
websites
and it was written by
a podcast producer for the southern
poverty law center
so um so it's pretty it's pretty pretty
messed up system um all of these people
basically you know these people are the
guys who work at silicon valley silicon
valleys fat checkers are overwhelmingly
uh ultra liberal they're very liberal
they are they they regard anything to
the right as fake news
they don't
fact check the left very often um so
it's it's got a very strong ideological
slant and because of that
you get the you see them getting things
wrong like for instance lovely
hypothesis they completely got that
wrong they thought it was a conspiracy
theory it's very clear that there's more
evidence now
for reliability
than there is but for a natural
religions hypothesis and this they got
this wrong because
they have this liberal mindset they
assume that donald trump was racist and
anybody who who believed in lovely
hypothesis was racist which makes no
sense because the alternative
explanation which is that it came from
chinese dietary habits is more racist
that's a lot more racist than believing
it came from a lab and yet they somehow
managed to because trump said it it was
by virtue that he was racist so that's
the first problem for the censorship is
that you can't actually determine what's
fake news or not because
it's very very heavily ideological
the second problem
with
it is that it interferes with our
natural adaptive processes so
you can't
uh get rid of all the misinformation in
the world you can only get rid of a
small proportion of it and some of the
time but what you're doing is you're
making people rely on you to tell you
what is true and what is false when you
when you when you choose what people can
and can't see and when you put these
kind of nutritional labels on on posts
to say oh this has been fat check and
proven to be false
what you're doing is you're you're not
allowing people to you know if you're
not exposing people to lies
then you're not giving them the
experience that they need in order to
work out what's true and what's false
for themselves you're basically spoon
feeding them what's true what's false
and so you're making people reliant on
your system to tell you to tell them
what is true and what is false
and that is a bad thing because if you
do that over a long enough period of
time eventually people are going to grow
dependent on that they're going to grow
dependent on organizations like facebook
to tell them what is true and what is
and that's very very dangerous you know
people should always try to work out for
themselves what is true what is false so
that's the second problem with
censorship and then obviously the third
problem is that web 3 is going to um
create this
division it's going to split the web
into basically where you're going to
have the old
web 2 users who are being spoon-fed
uh they're you know they're going to be
completely reliant on these centralized
structures to tell them what's true and
then you're going to have the web 3
people who are going to be
learning for themselves what's true and
what's false
and this is gonna
i mean this might be a bit of a you know
crazy thing to say but
you might know about the story um the
time machine by h.g wells and you've got
uh the morlocks and the eloy
so
so basically in this story this guy goes
into the far future and in the far
future
um
the morlocks basically human beings
divide they they divide into two
different subspecies
um the you've got the
eloy who basically live lives of luxury
and they have everything basically they
don't have to worry about anything and
they basically have everything pampered
and they have everything done for them
and as a result of that they grow very
very stupid they never have to use their
brains so their brains atrophy they
never have to use their bodies so their
body's atrophy
and so they become very weak and very
stupid and very naive and sort of you
know they believe the best and
everything and then underground you have
the morlocks who do all the work they do
all the toilet industrial toil
they live lives of hardship and as a
result of that they become very sort of
their brains over develop and their
muscles over develop and they basically
become the opposite of evil and so you
know in the end i mean you know it sort
of implied that the eloy will be
destroyed by the morlocks
um
i don't think that
that would go quite so far but
essentially
what would happen if we if we retain
this kind of
uh centralized structure on top of the
decentralized structure what's going to
happen is
people will be divided into two and
you'll have these kind of people who are
using web 2 who will be kind of eloy and
then you have people who are using web 3
who become kind of morocks so the people
who are using web 2 will be spoon-fed by
these
organizations you know they will
essentially brainwash them tell them
what's true and what's false
and then you'll have people who are sort
of using stuff themselves you know
finding out things for themselves and
they will have an advantage over the
people who are using
the web too so it's it's a bit of a
dangerous situation when you try to
regulate what people can and can't say
because in the long term it's going to
create disparities
um people you know you're going to
create people who are completely reliant
on others to tell them what's true and
what's false you're creating an entire
class of people who are essentially
sheep you know you get a matthew
principle with this as well right you're
going to get to the people who have the
ability to
understand technology and utilize the
way that web3 works and can fact-check
more effectively themselves they're
going to
you are going to end up with a
bifurcated culture if if web 3
takes off in the way that some people
think it might do
you are going to end up with
one group of people speaking one type of
language having a
a group of commonly held cultural
assumptions and then another group of
people who
have the old ones the ones that have
just been left behind
yeah absolutely i mean
and you know it sounds kind of
far-fetched but the thing is it's
already happening you know it's already
happening it's not something that we
have to wait and see um if you look at
for instance the way that sort of schism
has occurred between
liberals and conservatives um
the liberals are not eloise you know
they're not eloise and the conservatives
are not morlocks but the thing is is
that
the liberals tend to get their
information from the establishment
because the establishment is liberal
and then the conservatives are obviously
getting their
um information from alternative media
because the alternative media is now
mainly conservative or at least you know
right leaning might be libertarian um so
there's this kind of there's two
separate sources of information now in
the world and
these two groups are gradually diverging
as they sort of become trapped in these
in their own echo chambers and they you
know we saw it again going back to the
lovely hypothesis you know you had the
sort of the liberal establishment which
was firmly adamant that the lab leak
hypothesis was a racist conspiracy
theory and then you had the the sort of
right-wing
news media and the right-wing sort of
you know um information environment
which was
which which believed that you know it
was
it was not just a sort of
leap from a lab so many of them believed
it was a bio weapon and you know there
was all these other crazy theories um
coming out of that of that situation so
it's already beginning and i fear that
the sort of
if if web 3 is not sort of homogenous if
if it doesn't sort of
draw everyone and become truly sort of
egalitarian in its functionality
then it's gonna sort of exacerbate these
divisions
because you're gonna have these big
monolithic structures in silicon valley
regulating web 2.
obviously they will they will integrate
web 3 functionality but the very nature
of web 3 means that facebook is going to
have very limited power in a fully web3
environment
so
they're going to try to retain their
sort of power
by
limiting functionality and people who
are accustomed to using these big
monolithic structures won't want to
leave them so they'll retain you know
they'll retain it they will retain a
large audience even though there will be
some people who will migrate to sort of
you know mesh networks and and the like
um but yeah it's it's a very sort of
precarious situation and um
censorship is is not the way to to sort
of um
try to get people to believe truth
because
in the end you know all it's going to do
is just going to make people reliant on
others to tell them what's true which in
the long term is going to make them
completely you know
delusional
what can be asserted without evidence
can be dismissed without evidence if you
make a claim it's up to you to prove it
not me to disprove it
yeah
so um
this actually has a precursor um in uh
it was i mean it's famously attributed
to pitchings uh christopher hitchens you
know a lot of people love christopher
hitchens because he's a great speaker
and he's done a lot of great youtube
videos and that's how most people get to
know him um
but this was actually originally thought
of by a guy called bertrand russell
who's a great philosopher who was around
sort of the first half of the 20th
century
and um
he he had a concept called russell's
teapot
which was basically that
imagine there's a teapot
which is sort of orbiting the moon right
now
you can't prove that there is no teapot
there you know
and so because you can't prove that
there's no teapot there
if the onus is on you to disprove it
then you have to believe in pretty much
everything you have to believe in santa
claus because you can't disprove santa
claus you have to believe in zeus you
have to believe in poseidon you have to
believe in shiva you know you have to
believe in all these imaginary beings
because you can't disprove their
existence so the only way that you can
actually get through life um is by
assuming that what has been asserted
without evidence can be dismissed
without evidence because if you don't do
that
then you have to believe everything
essentially
so
it's it's basically a sort of it's a
system which ensures that
your mind is occupied by the minimum
amount of [ __ ] basically it's a it's
a
[ __ ] filtering
heuristic that's the best way to think
of it so few people use this though
because a lot of the time we have these
assertions that occur online and
people posit them
as if you should accept the fact that
they're there and you're like hang on a
second so here's a good example i had a
conversation with a buddy who did
philosophy at oxford uni and we were
talking about ethics and i've never
looked into ethics not like proper
philosophy uni
type of ethics and he said you can have
a conversation with somebody debating
about ethics
if you both agree on the meta ethical
framework that underpins it but if you
do not agree on the meta ethics then the
conversation about ethics just falls
apart because it's not grounded in
anything that you can both agree on it's
like look are we playing rugby or are we
playing football because we can debate
about or we can play the game of rugby
and football but if i kick it and you
pick it up this is no longer the same
game that we're playing and yeah this
this is the same with the hitchens razor
thing here people post stuff online
presuming that you're supposed to and
then you say well hang on a second like
that's not right you go everyone
believes that this is right what do you
mean what do you mean
yeah absolutely yeah i think um
this is actually the essence of
disagreement now on twitter really is
that people don't are not actually
disagreeing on facts or anything they're
actually disagreeing on the frameworks
by which they come to true
and so um yeah this is this is why
hitchens race is so important because
it's it's a short pithy thing that
everybody should learn because
you know all it's doing if you're if if
you
are expected to
disprove what somebody else is saying
all this is doing is wasting people's
time
because
it means that i could come out with
literally any claim you know there's no
there's no fill to them there's no
discrimination it's just like i could
just come out with anything and then
it's just going to waste people's time
when they have to disprove it so it's a
time saving device and it it's worked
wonders for me because i just you know i
think of the strength of the argument if
it's strong enough i will engage with it
if it's not it doesn't actually have a
strong evidence behind it it's not worth
my time the other thing it does is it
limits our own hubris about believing
our own [ __ ] right you say look hang
on a second like if i want to put
something forward i actually need to be
able to back this up and if i can't then
maybe i need to
shut my shut my pie hole right final
final couple a couple of my so the ones
that really intrigued me uh focusing
illusion nothing is ever as important
as what you're thinking about while
you're thinking about it for example
worrying about a thing makes the thing
being worried about seem worse than it
is as marcus aurelius observed we suffer
more in imagination than in reality
yeah
so
the mind works a lot like the eyes
um so the eyes can only focus on one
thing
at a certain time they cut when you look
at something when you look at anything
you kind of have to focus on something
or you have to just focus on nothing at
all
you can't focus on everything at the
same time
and the mind is exactly the same um if
you think about something you have to
think about you have to focus on that
thing you can't
when you imagine a system you have to
focus on a certain aspect of that system
you can't imagine the entire system
at once because it just your mind just
doesn't work like that it works by
picking out details and focusing on
those details
and the problem is is that when you
focus on certain aspects of a system or
a structure
your mind inflates the importance of
that
and so
it basically can you know if you spend
too long thinking about something
then that thing because it grows in
stature and it becomes something that
eventually can become an obsession
because you think it's so important and
i think this this kind of
can be seen in a way on
on twitter um
you know if you look at certain people
who
spend their lives you know um
with a single cause you know like one
cause candidates
of political um parties or even just
ordinary people who just have this one
issue that they're really really really
adamant about
what happens is that the more that they
focus on it
the more important it gets and so they
spend even more time on it and so it
becomes it gradually just snowballs into
this kind of obsession until they just
become more and more extreme and more
extreme and you can see it with someone
like tommy tommy robin's for instance um
you know he started off as a relatively
well-rounded fellow you know
and then gradually you know he had some
valid concerns about um islamism in in
bury park um and
he
decided to sort of devote his life to
islam you know to fighting it fighting
islamic islamic extremism
but then what happened was that because
he was spending so long thinking about
it
it began to seem like the entire world
to him
and so it sort of set off this threat
response in his brain where he began to
sort of you know feel this kind of
feeling that it was a sort of you know
it was encompassing him it was it was
basically uh something that he had to
defeat and this this conviction of his
got stronger and stronger the more he
thought about this problem
and so eventually you know when he was
on twitter you know he was just posting
never-ending just constant just spewing
out all this anti-islamic stuff you know
and it just gradually what it did is it
just kind of made him it was like a kind
of self-reinforcing became his own
caricature right yeah that's exactly
what happened he became a character of
himself and the reason that that
happened was essentially because of the
focusing illusion because he was
focusing on
islam at the expense of all the
surrounding context you know anything
else it was just literally just
islam islam islam islam and as a result
of that he became he just became
obsessed
and
it happens with everyone it's not just
you know
with people like tommy robinson this is
something that happens with pretty much
everybody i mean it's happened to me you
know sometimes if i've thought about a
certain thing
it kind of links in with the golden
hammer in a sense because
if somebody's written a book about a
certain concept they're going to be
thinking about that concept all the time
and that concept is going to seem more
important than it actually is and so
you're going to get people like tele who
are going to see things in the world and
they're going to think oh okay this is
this is explained by anti-fragility or
this is explained by the lindy effect or
black swans or you know all these other
concepts that he has it's it's because
the mind is incapable of seeing a system
as a whole it tends to just see the
constituent part and it tends to focus
on those
particular parts and as a result of that
you know
you can become blinded essentially by
what you focus on right last one
dunning-kruger effect awareness of the
limitations of cognition thinking
requires proficiency in metacognition
thinking about thinking in other words
being stupid makes you too stupid to
realize how stupid you are
yeah
um well i mean this one's quite
self-explanatory but i think i'll try to
expound upon it um
so
i think really this is kind of
the main obstacle to people educating
themselves and becoming more intelligent
because you can only remedy
something if you see the problem if you
actually know what the problem is
but the problem with
human minds is that they're incapable of
really comprehending themselves nobody
really understands
their own limitations you can't because
you can't step outside yourself you know
we we are we're sort of locked inside
our skulls
and that's what you know we have a very
limited perspective we can see the
outside world relatively well but we
can't see how we are ourselves we can't
see our own flaws very well we can't see
the limitations of our thinking very
well
and as a result of that we we often
there's a sort of correlation between
how
um
unintelligent you are
and how
ignorant of your own intelligence you
are so
you know people sort of who are very
ignorant
are obviously going to be ignorant of
themselves and so they're going to be
ignorant of their own stupidity
and their own ignorance
and so
it's very hard to remedy that you know
because what exactly are you supposed to
do if somebody can't recognize their own
ignorance
then
you can't really remedy it it's a bit of
a you know a bit of a sort of sticky
situation that people are sort of in so
i mean
one of the ways that you can try to
rectify it is by educating people about
the dunning-kruger effect
by actually telling people look
everybody is ignorant to a certain
extent
and the degree to which you're ignorant
limits
how aware of your ignorance you are how
do you think the dunning-kruger effect
relates to the midwit meme
um
i think it probably does explain it to a
certain extent i think um
when people are kind of uh you know when
they are not really aware of their own
flaws they will just tend to just not
bother trying to uh seek anything out of
their own comfort zone they won't you
know they won't really
uh they won't trying to find if you
think that what you believe if you think
that what you believe is right then
you're not going to try to correct it
you do you get what i'm saying so
these people are just going to carry on
believing what they already believe
they're just going to just sort of you
know
um they're not going to bother trying to
remedy because they're not even aware
that there's even a problem so
this i think is is the the crucial sort
of
uh element
of of midwife's and and not just the
midwifes but of everybody really i think
everybody has this problem this is not
you know this is not something that
anybody is immune to and we're all we're
all guilty of it and you know i myself
am ignorant about my own ignorance
there's a lot of things that i don't
know about myself that i'm ignorant of
so
it's something that we all have to
contend with you know this is uh this is
the problem but i think
i think that this is something that we
can only really remedy
um by making people aware of the done
kruger effect itself and also by making
people aware of cognitive biases
because when you when you're aware of
the way that your brain is working then
you can sort of um you can
take steps to to remedy it and i'll give
you an example how you do this
um
let's say
that you are an employer and you are
going to hire
one of two people uh person a and person
b and let's say person a
and person b have got the exact same
qualifications
um and they have pretty much they're
pretty much exactly the same in terms of
what their work history is and all that
kind of stuff
one of them is physically attractive and
one of them is not so who would you hire
in that situation
a lot of people would probably say oh i
would hire the physically attractive
person but that's actually wrong you
should actually hire the physically
unattractive person
because the physically unattractive
person has managed to get where they
have gotten
despite having
the ugliness the unattractiveness so
you're basically second guessing your
own bias
you know you're basically saying you're
basically saying okay so there is
actually a bias at work here and that
person has overcome that bias so they
must be more competent than the
attractive person
so you can do it through these little
full experiments like that you know you
can try to teach people to be aware of
their own biases
which can
go some way to remedy the dunny creeper
effect but you'll never be able to
completely
um you know be aware of every problem
that you have in your own thinking
because just thinking just doesn't work
that way matt we'll just hold our hands
up and and allow ourselves to be carried
away by a tidal wave of nihilism look
dude we made it thank you so much for
coming on today what should people do if
they enjoyed this and want to check out
more of your stuff where should they go
yeah so um the best way to keep in touch
with me is on twitter so uh you can
follow me at um
g underscore s underscore bogel that's b
h o g a l um and i've also got a sub
stack on the horizon which i'm going to
be opening soon i'm going to be
exploring a lot of these concepts in
more detail in essay form which is you
know certainly a couple of weeks away
now so uh that's something that i'll be
doing soon as well and yeah hopefully
i'll go to
increase the understanding of these
concepts sick man we'll just write some
more threads and then we can do some
more episodes that's what i want yeah
yeah more threads will be coming as well
yeah this is something i'm going to
start doing semi-regularly so uh yeah i
think i'll probably try and get another
thread out for the end of the year and
then we'll see what goes from there good
man catch you later on dude
cheers thanks chris thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that then
press here for a selection of the best
clips from the podcast over the last few
months and don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace